[Music]
let's go to
taylor in chicago illinois taylor how
can we help
hey guys i feel so privileged to talk to
you both oh
well we are the one that are privileged
so what's going on
so about a year and a half ago my
husband
would let go um it
basically in a nutshell he really
struggled to communicate
boundaries at work and it wasn't like
they were
asking him to work more than 40 hours
but the kind of work that they were
putting on his plate
was so high intense that when he did ask
for more help
um it was refused and they told him to
do a time study and
it was kind of a mess um i should
process that by saying
he's like crazy gifted and
efficient and so they even they told him
he was going to get a raise and
then they never delivered but they still
added more on his plate
without said rays and so
it really started affecting our home
life um
you know our marriage and our children
and just
so many things and then when things got
to a really bad breaking point um
you know it just it just couldn't be in
the ministry anymore
so we're in a much better spot now
praise god i mean
like i said he's been home for a year
and a half he thank god he has a deep
youtube channel that does really well um
but we're
really committed to getting out of this
little debt that we have left um so he's
got a warehouse job on the weekends but
the end goal is to maybe get back in
ministry but we're so terrified
so terrified because he's terrified and
i'm perfect because what if it happens
again like what if we fail to set those
boundaries or
he fails to set those boundaries and
he's a yes guy like
you know if if you want him to jump
he'll say how high where
how long and he's just he's an amazing
worker and you're an amazing purpose
person yeah but it ended up filling into
other parts of our family and life and
it's just
yeah uh john
is going to jump in here it can really
help uh but i'm curious
what position was he in and it was it a
para church ministry was it a church
it was a church he was a pastor staff
pastor um
a worship pastor and he i mean like i
said they gave
well they promised to raise and and then
after finally
asking three times hey where's the
raisers raised we finally gave it but it
wasn't nearly what it was promised yeah
okay so
i want john to speak to the boundaries
issue but i want to make a statement
that i hope you take back to your
husband
um maybe maybe he can watch this on
youtube because we're talking about him
yeah um yeah he's called but like i said
he's working pretty much 80 hours a week
now
yeah well so here's the deal the fear
that every church leadership structure
is going to be like it was is just
nonsense
it's just nonsense he knows what an
unhealthy leadership structure looks
like
he can identify it he can taste it smell
it point it out a mile away
and he needs to be armed with that
confidence that that's not always going
to be the case
but he's a part of the equation too
that's where i hand the baton to my
much more capable on his boundary issues
well
you know i mean i could guess what it is
but not talking to him
but uh he he can't assume so that fear
is misguided right that needs to be
just blown up but his boundary issue is
part of the problem
here's here's a big part the fear is the
fear is real
it's real yeah so what's happened is you
guys got fried
right and now both your hearts and your
brains are scanning
every possible environment that looks
similar to say hey we know this story
and it hurt us
so i'm going to keep us out of that
right
and to ken's point that's that's not a
fair representation
on the other side if as you say
he can't say no he won't do boundaries
he will say yes to everything
i'm going to tell you don't go into
ministry because
he's going to make relationships with
people who love him and then they're
going to be hurt when that thing goes
south
and if he can't say no if he can't
establish a
what is my work daily job what is my
salary what are the raised structures
what is my responsibilities when i'm off
if he can't do that
then he doesn't have the other side of
the skill set of taking care of people
which is taking care of yourself
right right which i should say that he
has come
i i was listening you know i we listened
to you guys every day our kids pretty
much asked us when we're going to be on
the dave ramsey
doing our debt free scream um but
he's come so so far sure it's not like
we're roommates anymore
it used to be like that i used to tell
him two years ago i just feel like we're
just
living together and just kind of going
in circles
um so he's i mean when i told you that
he's put in the work
i've we read the proximity principle
this past month
i mean we're going through books and
we're he's and i want to be his
cheerleader and so he's
he's working on setting those boundaries
if that makes sense
but it's still like it's still a
struggle
here's a great way you can bring it in
the smallest places here's a great way
you can do it
when there are boundaries to be set in
your home and i'm talking about little
stuff
like somebody knocks on the door and
normally you would go answer it and say
um no thank you we're not interested he
gets to go do that
and when he comes back i want him to
verbalize to you
to be vulnerable and say that made me
uncomfortable
not listening to the whole pitch and go
ahead and buying the magazines even
though i didn't want them
if his mom or your mom or somebody's
family or somebody's friends invite you
all out and y'all don't want to go
he is the guy that's not going to text
he's going to call him and say
hey thanks for the invite we're not
going to be able to make it this time no
excuses
no but next time it just say
um we're not going to be able to make it
this time but we look forward to
catching up next time then hang up and
then i want him to turn and look at you
and verbalize what am i feeling here
and all we're trying to do is two things
number one he's got to practice
boundaries
and if he waits till the game to take a
shot
then he's going to miss the shot right
so he's going to practice you're going
to help him practice
and two i want him to verbalize these
feelings that he feels that insecurity
that nervousness
his heart starts racing they're not
going to kill him in fact they're
normal right and so you're going to
practice and practice and practice
and then yeah when he goes in to apply
for a job at his next church
he's going to know hey i got burned on
this stuff last time i learned a great
lesson
now i know the questions to ask and if
the community is not right the
community's not right
but practice boundaries just like you
would any other skill
right yeah i just want to reiterate what
john said that i agree i think he does
need to get help
and even counseling that's great
counseling right there but i want him to
get to the bottom of why he feels he's
got to say yes
because if he feels called i think he's
got to do it
yeah but john's right don't get back
into ministry until he's healthy
and he can do it right uh that's good
but thank you for the call you guys are
amazing you're killing it by the way
he's a great guy i love it he's busting
right now what a stud and remind him
that you appreciate how hard he's
working that might be a little fun thing
you need to hear
as well
[Music]